تفخر آيسلندا باستخدامها
لمصادر الطاقة المتجددة ، وتقول الحكومة إن
حوالي 85 من إجمالي إمدادها بالطاقة
يأتي من مزيج من مصادر الطاقة الكهرومائية
والحرارية الأرضية ، وهي أعلى
نسبة من الطاقة المتجددة لأي
دولة في العالم ، ولكنها أيضًا تستخدم
هذه الطاقة المتجددة لالتقاط  وتخزين
الكربون CO2 وتخزينه أو ccs هو أحد
التقنيات العديدة التي تقول IPCC إنها
يمكن أن تساعد في تقليل الاحتباس الحراري
وتجنب كارثة المناخ
، وللقيام بذلك ، فإن هذه المراوح العملاقة
تمتص ثاني أكسيد الكربون مباشرة من
الهواء المحيط تمامًا مثل المكنسة الكهربائية العملاقة
أولاً و  في المقام الأول ، نحتاج إلى التوقف عن
انبعاث ثاني أكسيد الكربون وعلينا إزالة الكربون من
أنظمة الطاقة لدينا ، ولكن بالإضافة إلى
ذلك نحتاج إلى تخزين الكثير من ثاني أكسيد
الكربون وهذا هو في الغالب ثاني أكسيد الكربون مشتق من
العمليات الصناعية التي سنظل
نعتمد عليها على الرغم من أننا تمكنا من ذلك  التخلص
التدريجي من الوقود
الأحفوري الطريقة التي طورتها شركة carpex
هي تمعدن ثاني أكسيد الكربون لذلك بشكل أساسي لتحويل
ثاني أكسيد الكربون إلى حجر ، ولهذا نحتاج إلى
نوع معين من الصخور البركانية الصخرية مثل
باسات محطة الطاقة الحرارية الأرضية هذه حيث تعمل snibias dottier على
عملية التمعدن وهذه الأكواخ الثلجية
هي المكان الذي تحدث
فيه الأنابيب هنا قناة co2 الممزوجة بالمياه
الجوفية على عمق حوالي 800
متر أو أكثر من 2  600 قدم من
هذه الصخور قابلة للنفاذ للغاية ، لذا فهي
تشبه الإسفنج ، ولدينا الكثير
من المسام والكسور لتدفق مائع مخطط ثاني أكسيد الكربون من
خلالها ، وقد
قُدر أنك تعرف أنه يمكن تخزين أكثر من 100 كيلوغرام
من ثاني أكسيد الكربون في كل متر مكعب
يأتي ثاني أكسيد الكربون من مصدرين أحدهما هو
محطة الطاقة الحرارية الجوفية نفسها ،
وهي بالطبع طاقة خضراء ، لكنها لا تزال
تنبعث منها بعض ثاني أكسيد الكربون الذي
ينبعث منه هذا النبات حوالي ثلاثة في المائة
مما ينبعث من محطة حرق الوقود الأحفوري
ذات الحجم المماثل
المصدر الثاني لثاني أكسيد الكربون هو
الغلاف الجوي  وهذا هو المكان الذي
يأتي
فيه المشجعون إلى مصنع Orca الذي سمي على اسم الكلمة الأيسلندية
للطاقة التي تديرها شركة سويسرية
تسمى أعمال التسلق التي يقولون إنها أفضل ما
في العالم  r هي أكبر منشأة لالتقاط الهواء المباشر ،
فهي تلتقط حوالي أربعة
آلاف طن من ثاني أكسيد الكربون سنويًا ، لكن من المتوقع أن ينتج
عن الطلب العالمي على الطاقة لعام 2021 وحده
33 مليار طن
[موسيقى] ،
لذلك من المنطقي أن يصبح
انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون أكثر تكلفة بكثير.
نحتاج إلى البدء في وضع علامة السعر الحقيقي
على انبعاثاتنا ، لا يمكننا الاستمرار
في المضي قدمًا على هذا النحو حيث يكون في الواقع
أرخص بكثير لمجرد تركها ،
كما أن طريقة التقاط الكربون وتخزينه هذه
تستهلك الكثير من الطاقة بشكل لا يصدق
خاصة في موقع الالتقاط ، ويجادل بعض
النقاد  أن العملية
ستؤخر الصناعات من التحول
بعيدًا عن الوقود الأحفوري ،
يجب ألا تستخدم هذه التقنية لإزالة
الكربون من صناعتك
أولاً وقبل كل شيء يجب عليك
التخلص من انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون قدر الإمكان ،
حيث يعد تخزين الكربون حلاً
وهو أحد الحلول العديدة
أننا بحاجة إلى التنفيذ ، لا يمكننا تحقيق
أهداف اتفاقية باريس دون
تخزين كميات هائلة من ثاني أكسيد الكربون
بالنظر إلى ما وراء الكربوهيدرات في آيسلندا
أنشأ fix قاعدة بيانات عالمية لإظهار
المكان الذي يمكن فيه استخدام تكوينات البازلت
الأخرى لتخزين ثاني أكسيد الكربون
، كما أنه ينشئ خطة
لأسطول من السفن المصممة خصيصًا
لنقله ،
فأنت تعرف نظام التوزيع الذي
وضعناه لتكون قادرًا على
التوزيع  كل هذا النفط والغاز في
جميع أنحاء العالم وفي كل مكان بعيد ،
أعني منك معرفة
حقول النفط البحرية عبر خطوط الأنابيب عبر الحدود
والسفن وأيًا كان ما أعنيه ،
فهذا ربما لا يكون خيال علمي كما نعتقد
أخبرنا كيف ترد على
المكالمة باستخدام علامة التصنيف على الأرض